hey guys my name is achernar and welcome
to the brilliant maths episode on flappy
bird series today we'll be talking about
maths a lot let's start with vectors a
vector is generally an entity that has a
direction and a length however commonly
in graphics programming a vector is a
way to represent a coordinate firstly
we'll need to make a new class which
will hold this vector entity I'm going
to right click on the flappy folder and
select new class since factors directly
refer to maths it makes sense to pop the
vector class into the math package so
that all of our maths classes have their
own folder in the source code I'm going
to call this class vector 3f the 3 means
the vector has three components and the
F refers to the data type of the
components in this case floats
now as you can see we have a new folder
in our project called math which is
going to hold all of our math stuff once
we have our class I'm going to go ahead
and create three fields at the top which
represent the components of the vector x
y&z I'll make them public so that we can
easily change them whenever we need
finally I'll make a constructor that
takes in three parameters and
appropriately sets the fields to the
parameters this will help us quickly
create a new vector when we need to I'll
also make one more constructor that
takes in no parameters this will simply
set all the components to zero honestly
that's all we need for our vector class
we could write numerous and different
operations for our vectors such as the
dot and cross-product reflection
normalization calculations or even just
simply addition and subtraction but the
truth is we really don't need them for
this series in fact you could get away
without creating this class at all but
it will keep you more organized what we
will need though without doubt is a
matrix class let's create a new class in
our mouth folder called matrix for F the
four means the matrix is a four by four
matrix
holding 16 elements in all the elements
are floats
hence the F let's click finish matrices
are much more complicated than vectors
but they're essentially just an array or
a bunch of numbers commonly shown in
between two large square brackets they
have columns and they have rows we've
made a four by four matrix so we have 16
of those numbers or elements in our
array I'm not even going to pretend to
explain how matrices work in this video
so if you don't know how they work I
recommend you check out any math
textbook or video that talks about
matrices how they work in graphics
programming is identical to general
mathematics although graphics
programming has certain special types of
matrices and equations as I just
mentioned matrices are essentially
arrays thus we'll express our matrix in
Java using a public array of floats
which has the size of 16 the reason I
wrote 4 times 4 instead of 16 is simply
so that the code makes more sense since
this is a 4 by 4 matrix
note that this is going to be a single
dimensional array that's because it will
be easier to pass them to OpenGL since
open GL does not want multi-dimensional
arrays the first thing we'll need to
create is an identity matrix an identity
matrix is a special type of matrix in
which all
in the main diagonal are equal to one
and everything else is zero this matrix
is essentially just the number one since
when we multiply any appropriate matrix
by this identity matrix it's equivalent
to multiplying any single number by one
so this matrix a multiplied by our
identity matrix will equal a the first
thing I'm going to do is create a for
loop which will fill every element in
the matrix with 0 then I'll need to set
the main diagonal elements to 1 to do
that I'll access our matrix array and
then use coordinate system to set the
appropriate values here I'm setting the
first element to one point zero F let's
take a quick look at this coordinate
system the first number refers to the
row of our matrix the second refers to
the column of our matrix and finally
we'll multiply that by the constant
width of our matrix which is 4 obviously
we could have just written 0 for this
one but writing it out this way makes
much more sense let's continue with
setting each of the elements in our main
diagonal to 1
finally we will return this matrix and
our identity method is complete note
that I've made this method static
because it returns a new matrix almost
like a constructor there are three main
operations we need to give our matrix
for this game multiply translate and
rotate multiplying two matrices together
isn't as straightforward as you might
think again I suggest you at a maths
book on this matter to understand more
clearly simply put when multiplying to
4x4 matrices together a and B we take
each element from a zeros separately
multiplying it with each element from
B's column and then add them all
together
we do this for each of us rose and bears
columns
since we'll be using column-major
ordering for our matrices we need to
flip this method as columns will be
multiplied with B's rows more on column
major ordering later in this multiply
method we're going to be returning a new
matrix that is the result of our current
matrix multiplied by the matrix that's
in the parameter to express this more
concisely in our code we can use a for
loop particularly three nested for loops
as shown here the first two loops go
through each of the elements in the row
and column while the third is in charge
of multiplying the elements together and
adding them to the overall sum of the
resulting element are shown in the
equation before note the difference in a
rain disease that's because the first
matrix takes elements from its column
and multiplies them with the elements in
the row of the second Matrix then we'll
return the result of our multiplication
if you don't quite understand how this
works try writing the original equation
down on paper and then walk through this
code step by step papers words at the
translate method is used in graphics
programming to move an object around 2d
or 3d space one thing I want to mention
straight away is that OpenGL typically
takes column major ordering for matrices
as I mentioned earlier which means that
the elements are ordered moving down the
column not across rows row major
matrices can easily be transposed views
in OpenGL as you'll see later but we're
just going to go ahead and use column
major ordering anyway what that means is
that when we look at the following
translation matrix that we need to code
these three elements actually refer to
the 12 13 and 14
index in our array not the 3rd 7th and
11th translate will take in a vector and
then set the appropriate elements to the
values of that vector as you saw in the
diagram that's all there is to it
the rotation method is a bit more
involved firstly we'll need a bunch of
mouths operations so let's scroll up to
the top and import driver's mouth class
as static so that we don't have to type
in math dot every time we need something
static from the math class one thing I
want to mention is that we really only
need z-axis rotation since this is a 2-d
game because of that we can use this
matrix but be warned this matrix only
supports rotation along the z axis
firstly java's math class takes in
angles as radians
whereas we as humans would much rather
think about degrees let's make a
variable called R which converts our
angle into radians we'll need to cause
it to afloat since java's to radians
method returns a double then we'll
simply take the cosine and sine about
fresh Radian angle so that we don't have
to keep recalculating it in the future
now we simply need to set the
appropriate elements in the matrix equal
to that of the diagram so let's do the
first column first and then the second
column now we're ready to return it and
we're done in case you wanted rotation
around all the axes here's what the
implementation of that would look like
the XY and set parameters should either
be 0 or 1 and they indicate which axes
the rotation should occur around since
we only need z-axis rotation I'm going
to get rid of this method since we'll
never use it in this series these two
methods that we just created translate
and rotate will be used to transform
objects in our game including the map
and the bird finally just one more
matrix operation remains the projection
matrix a projection matrix in OpenGL
refers to how objects are displayed on
the screen basically there are two
choices orthographic or perspective
perspective is similar to orthographic
with one main difference objects that
are further away are rendered smaller
kind of how our eye see in the real
world since this is a 2-d game however
we're need realistic depth so I'm going
to implement the orthographic matrix
left right top and bottom refer to the
clipping margins of our viewport
basically they define the margins of the
window through which we look into the
world anything outside these margins is
not rented similarly near and far define
the distance at which we render objects
anything too close or too far as set by
those values will not be rented we'll
see this in action soon again we start
with the identity matrix set the
appropriate elements as per the diagram
and return the result and that's all the
maths out of the way
LW JGL doesn't take default Java arrays
when it sends data to OpenGL LW JGL
wants float buffers instead of float
arrays also we're going to need a way to
load textures and shaders into the game
looks like next episode will be all
about utility classes thanks for
watching and I hope you enjoyed this
episode of let's make flappy bird as
always alike is greatly appreciated and
I'll see you guys in the next episode
goodbye